turning to ukraine where officials say
10 000 civilians trapped in a city under
russian attack in the east cannot be
evacuated
the war is also having growing
international impact president zielinski
said last night that russia's naval
blockade could lead to starvation for
millions of people around the world
because ukraine cannot export its wheat
and corn chris livesay has the story
during an air raid it's a question of
life or death risk of shelling or risk
not eating russian forces have attacked
both the food and water supply forcing
the people of mikolayev to line up for
rations of both
i'm looking after two grandmothers 189
the other 97 says natalia they're too
afraid to leave the house
that's where world central kitchen comes
in a charity cooking hot meals and
delivering them to civilians soldiers
even russian pows no matter the risk was
this a cluster bomb yes it was clustered
i see a hole right here right above my
head yes
russian warships and russian mines are
blockading ukrainian ports holding
hostage more than 20 million tons of
grain earmarked for the developing world
and worsening a global food crisis
but there's also a local food crisis
with 45 percent of ukrainians struggling
to find enough to eat according to the
world food program
that's because wheat fields have become
minefields and when farmers try to farm
they risk getting blown off their
tractors by russian rockets that's what
happened to sergey just out of surgery
shrapnel tore through his lung liver and
narrowly missed his heart
for attacking civilians he says they're
bastards
now if this city falls there is little
stopping russian forces from capturing
odessa and with it the entire coast of
the black sea the mayor says the last
hope is those advanced weapon systems on
route from the united states but that's
if they get here in time tony
that is an if crystal to say force in
ukraine chris thank you very much